so with little rocket man trying to
threaten to pull out of the upcoming
summit with president Trump due to the
ongoing military exercises that he knew
about between South Korea in the u.s.
well despite this recent development
president Trump has made a massive
improvements in gains in the Korean
Peninsula and by the way some would
argue his tough talk his military
presence his sanctions all work take a
listen
Korea best not make any more threats to
the United States they will be met with
fire and fury like the world has never
seen the United States has great
strength and patience but if it is
forced to defend itself for its allies
we will have no choice but to totally
destroy North Korea rocket man is on a
suicide mission for himself and for his
regime
this shouldn't be handled now but I'm
going to handle it because we have to
handle it little rocket man we're going
to do it because we really have no
choice
what's amazing is the president's tough
rhetoric towards North Korea proves what
Ronald Reagan spoke about in the 1980s
concerning the evil empire the Soviet
Union when he talked about peace through
strength trust but verify
what's this there is one sign the
Soviets can make that would be
unmistakable that would advance
dramatically dramatically the cause of
freedom and peace general secretary
Gorbachev if you seek peace if you seek
prosperity for the Soviet Union and
Eastern Europe if you seek
liberalization
come here to this gate mr. Gorbachev
open this gate mr. Gorbachev tear down
this wall his own aides didn't want him
to say those words you can't forget
Reagan's trust but verify approach
towards the evil empire take a look we
have listened to the wisdom of in an old
Russian Maxim and I'm sure you are
familiar with it
my semester general secretary though my
pronunciation may give you difficulty
the maxim is Dovie I know probe I trust
but verify Gorbachev laughing all right
why this is significant there's a brand
new book out it's amazing it's called
three days in Moscow Ronald Reagan in
the fall of the Soviet empire you know
him well
he's the anchor a special reporter
friend of repair we're not friends every
every newspaper don't they have a
section in local international national
that's right and they have a sports
section that's exactly right
they have an editorial page and do
indeed I might the editorial page you
are and Dan you're the news page that's
right
this is an amazing book because it's so
relevant to Iran and North Korea and
even the opening of the embassy in
Jerusalem listen remember those times
when Reagan was speaking out about the
evil empire about the ash heap of
history the communism would be you know
joking at times getting caught like the
bombing is gonna start tomorrow heads
were exploding in Washington at the time
sound familiar
heads are exploding in Washington now if
June 12th holds and the summit in
singapore happens june 12th is historic
June 12 1987 is when Reagan delivers the
Brandenburg Gate speech tear down this
wall
mr. Gorbachev and that changed the world
those summits and the collection of them
you know changed our history it's
possible you know look at what already
the president without flying in cargo
planes of cash and other currencies like
Obama did or Clinton with the energy
aide to Kim jong-un's father Kim you
don't know
but this president talked tough put a
military presence also a relationship
with the Chinese President and sanctions
in place aren't didn't that really all
contribute to Kim jong-un's decision
here I would think so now the the the
caveat is that North Koreans don't have
a great history living up to their
promises so the president has said he's
gonna sit at the table and walk away if
the deals not right oh let's just like
Reykjavik and just like Reykjavik I mean
the the similarities are really stark
personalities are different
I don't think Reagan would love Twitter
but who knows maybe he would but he did
say those bold things that changed the
paradigm and maybe the paradigm she was
studying the thing is they said he was a
California cowboy they said he would
start World War 3
they said Reaganomics would result in
the collapse of the economy 21 million
new jobs were created we doubled Rudd
revenues to the federal government and
had the longest period of peacetime
economic growth in history do you see
the similarities I know I'm dragging a
little into opinion do you see
similarities I do and I say it in the
book the last word of this book I to
that page it I'm only happy you're
getting there yeah but if you look at
the words of big speeches of President
Trump the speech in Warsaw Poland the
speech in Riyadh the United Nations
speech the State of the Union speech
they have phrases and terminology that
you could actually hear Reagan
delivering now I'm not saying that
President Trump is President Reagan
President Reagan
very different personalities I but they
have similar moments and challenges that
they're facing peace through strength
trust but verify
tax cuts now we've had the Trump tax
cuts originalist on the Supreme Court
securing the border I I don't believe
that this president as a national as
populist as some have said I believe he
is a Reagan conservative the things that
I just mentioned energy independence are
all things that Reagan believed in am I
wrong you're not wrong and I also think
that there is the possibility that this
president has the
to reach out to Democrats and make some
deals that Reagan would even with Tip
O'Neill and others all right the book is
fascinating I'm saying this is not only
as a friend I really have always loved
Reagan it is an amazing read and it's so
relevant ripped from today's headlines
and so many similarities great book how
much crap do you take for being for me
being opinionated on a scale of one to
ten or I'm gonna scale one of them you
know it's a good six just tell everybody
your news I'm opinion every newspaper is
a news section sports section in the
Hannity sex I do I do
great book thanks man